this is weird because it's really hard
for me to watch myself whenever I do
anything
[Music]
that was great whale good for you
talking whale it's just like hearing
myself which is even worse you know when
you hear yourself on tape so it's going
to be torture now that I think about it
what am I thinking
[Music]
hopefully that's all right and so you do
the thing whatever it is the line 90
times and you have a director who helps
you by saying it's almost like you're a
kid and when you want to Bicycle he gave
me freedom to go wherever I wanted to go
so I I uh I took him up on that and went
crazy with it so my goal would be to
make them laugh and I would go and go
and go until they would they couldn't
hold I could I could see that they were
trying to stop laughing because they
would be in front of me and then finally
they would just lose it
yeah
offended him maybe a different dialect
I didn't even think about that going in
but your voice is the only thing you
have to get emotion across and every
single tiny Nuance is important come on
yes I'm a natural Blues
for the longest time I just thought it
was me in the movie until I saw the
Billboards go up and I said what's a
shark doing in the movie I thought it
was just me it's wild to be by yourself
that whole time three years I've been
working on it I know a lot of what I did
in it and I know the story and I
remember the story obviously but
um it's going to be very weird to see uh
me and and because I know from watching
the other Pixar films I started caring
about toys I started really getting you
you believe they're real so it's going
to be weird to see me as a fish and and
get invested I'll probably be too close
to it anyway I forget things almost
instantly it runs in my family well I
mean at least I think it does
um
thank you
can I help you it's a whole world down
there that unless you scuba dive which I
never have I mean I've snorkeled just
for the first time actually last summer
and it is incredible because you can go
in water but until you actually put that
mask on and look down and see that world
that exists down there and I can't
imagine what it what it would be like to
scuba dive and this kind of from what I
see it it feels like you would be in
that world and hopefully that's what
this movie will do it makes people start
paying attention more to to the ocean
and to fish and to have you know respect
for for that life you know what you got
to do I don't want to know what you got
to do just keep swimming just keep
swimming just keep swimming swimming
swimming it sounds really corny but
that's why I'm proud to be a part of a
movie like this because there aren't too
many movies that are number one Timeless
and that's the kind of Comedy that I
appreciate and this kind of movie where
kids can go and get it and it's smart
and it's funny and it's kind and it's
positive it's not violent it's not
negative and yet I appreciate it and
adults appreciate it because it's so
clever and it's so smart it's just so
funny and and so it's a it really is a
movie that every age group can
appreciate on on on different levels
to swim you see I'm gonna get stuck now
with that song now it's in my head sorry